hello and welcome to the android
application development course offered
by simply learn
in this course we will learn how to
develop android applications and use
different controls we will also see how
to publish your own application in
google play having basic knowledge of
java would be an added advantage for
this course on completing this course
successfully you will be able to develop
and publish an android application on
your own let us start with chapter one
introduction to android application
development by understanding the
objectives
by the end of this lesson
you will be able to explain the
architecture of android operating system
list the components of android
application describe the activity and
life cycle of activity explain stack of
activity explain service its use and
importance we will also discuss what
broadcast receiver is and why it is used
we will finally move on to discuss
content provider and its benefits
in this section we will discuss the
architecture of android operating system
in detail
the architecture of android operating
system is divided into the following
sections
linux kernel
libraries and android runtime
application framework and applications
in the next few slides we will discuss
each of these in detail
let us look at the first of the android
operating system architecture sections
linux kernel the linux 2.6 kernel
provides services like security
memory management process management
network stack driver model and power
management it is reliable and also acts
as an abstraction layer between the
hardware and the rest of the software
stack next we will understand libraries
android includes a set of libraries from
c or c plus libraries like libsy and ssl
some of the common libraries in android
and their functions are as follows
surface manager manages access to the
display system sqlite provides a native
but powerful database support for
android apps
media framework allows playing audio and
video files and viewing images sgl and
opengl and es are the most commonly used
graphics libraries
free type renders bitmap and vector
fonts with which you can customize fonts
in your apps
ssl or secured socket layer offers
security during internet browsing
webkit helps to integrate internet
browsers in android applications
after discussing libraries let us move
on to understand android runtime
android runtime is divided into two
parts core libraries and dvm
core libraries provide nearly all the
functionalities that are available in
the core libraries of the java
programming language
dalvik virtual machine dvm is register
based and optimized in such a way that a
device can run a number of different
instances of dbm with the help of
multi-threading so that the application
runs very efficiently every application
runs with its own instance of dbms
separately just as in linux
moving on let us now learn about the
application framework application
framework is a rich set of classes that
helps in the faster development of an
android application it is an open source
development platform
it offers the ability to develop rich as
well as innovative applications using
the android
also it offers an abstraction to
hardware access and manages user
interface ui and applications resources
in this slide we will discuss the last
of the android operating system
architecture sections
applications applications are written in
java programming language
examples include messaging calendar
google maps web browser and music player
uis user interfaces of android
applications can be designed by using
programming languages such as java and
xml
with this we come to the end of our
discussion on the architecture of
android operating system
let us now start with the components of
android application
there are four basic components of an
namely
activity
service
broadcast receiver and content provider
let us learn about these components in
detail in the subsequent slides
in this slide we will discuss the first
component activity
what is an activity and why do we use it
an activity represents a single screen
with ui or window to create an activity
or window
inherit activity class from the android
dot app package
activity class creates a window in which
ui can be placed with the method set
content view view
while activities are often presented as
full screen windows they can also be
used as floating windows or embedded
inside another active the oncreate
bundle is where you initialize your
activity all activity classes must have
a corresponding activity declaration in
their packages androidmanifest.xml
if we do not register or declare
activity and manifest file the
application will crash and will give the
message unfortunately stopped manifest
is a simple xml file which keeps track
of all required information about an
application
such as version permissions required
activities services
broadcast receiver and content provider
in the next slide
we will discuss the life cycle of an
activity
the main functions in the life cycle of
an activity are oncreate function
onstart function
onresume function
onpause function
onstop function
onrestart function ondestroy function
oncreate is the entry level function for
an activity like the main function in
java when you run an android app only
oncreate function will work whereas
onstart function and onresume function
will be skipped to understand other
functions of activity life cycle let us
take an example suppose while playing
games you get a call on your android
the game will be paused actually android
operating system will call on pause
function for that game where the game
developer may have written code to pause
the game and when you wish to resume the
game you can resume it from where you
stopped before taking the call this can
be done using on resume function
sometimes between applications we hit
the home button of the android device or
phone to go back to the home screen in
such cases onstop function will work and
stop your application your application
will remain in memory
the application is not killed but is
running in the background when you open
the same application again it will open
from where you were before hitting the
home button
on restart function and onstart function
will work here and when you press back
to exit from the application ondestroy
function will run
the image of the activity lifecycle is
given on the screen
now let us learn about activity stack
the android environment maintains a
stack of all the open activities for
every application a separate stack is
maintained in memory when an activity is
opened or when we start a new activity
an entry is added to the stack when an
activity is closed the last entry will
be deleted from the stack in the next
slide we will understand the next
component
service
a service is a component that runs in
the background to perform long-running
operations or work for remote processes
each service class must have a
corresponding service declaration in its
packages android manifest dot xml a
service does not provide user interface
another component such as an activity
can start the service and let it run or
bind it to an interact with it for
example suppose you have set an alarm
for a meeting the next day at one pm for
setting the alarm you need some user
interface but once you save it it will
scan for the right date and time in the
background and will raise the alarm on
the respective date and time to create a
service inherit service class from the
android dot app package service has
three main methods namely oncreate
function onstart function and on destroy
function
in this slide let us look into broadcast
receiver
broadcast receiver listens to broadcast
intents it will receive messages
broadcasted by the android operating
system from time to time and this is why
it is called broadcast receiver it must
be registered either in code or within
the android manifest dot xml an intent
filter must be used to specify the
intents it is listening for a broadcast
receiver can be registered using
multiple intent filters the on receive
function method has to be overridden to
perform any operations using broadcast
receiver let us take the same example of
the alarm again you have set an alarm
and your phone is dead due to the
battery having drained out or some other
reason
after restart would you like to restart
the application or wait for it to start
automatically the android environment
broadcasts some messages as it starts we
can receive those messages if we have
written broadcast receiver and
automatically start application or
service again let us understand more
about content provider in the next slide
content provider is one of the primary
building blocks of android applications
that provide content to applications it
encapsulates and provides data to
applications through a single interface
called content resolver a content
provider is only required if the data
has to be shared between multiple
applications for example the contacts
data is used by multiple applications
and must be stored in a content provider
such as whatsapp or truecaller which
reads contact's information and lets the
user know from whom they are getting a
call this brings us to the end of this
topic
in the next few slides we will
understand more about adt bundle for
android
adt bundle is a set of latest android
sdk eclipse and sdk manager in this
course we will use the google adt bundle
for developing android applications
for this
download the latest adt bundle from http
colon forward slash forward slash
developer.android.com
navigate to get the sdk and click on
download eclipse adt for your operating
system
to start developing the android
application unzip the adt bundle before
you open eclipse from adt bundle ensure
that you have the latest jbk installed
on your machine
let us look into the new topic android
virtual device or emulator
android virtual device avd or emulator
is a logical device where you can
install run and test your application on
your machine there is no need to copy
the android binary every time to a
physical device everything can be
emulated on a virtual device or emulator
the only thing that requires a physical
device is vibration to create android
virtual device follow the steps
mentioned below
in eclipse go to window then go to
android virtual device manager click new
in android virtual device tab to create
avd for the first time then enter
credentials like avd
name
select device front and back camera
ram
internal storage and sd card keep
hardware keyboard present checked it
will allow you to use the keyboard
then click ok
finally to launch avd select avd and
click start and then launch
let us discuss a new topic ddms in
android
in this slide we will learn about ddms
ddms is the abbreviation for dalvik
debug monitor server it is used to
emulate gps and other things on emulator
ddms gives information about thread heap
process radio state etc
one can capture the screen using ddms
ddms can be opened by following the
steps given below
in eclipse
go to the window menu go to open
perspective option
select other from list and select ddms
before we summarize go through the quiz
section to check your understanding of
this lesson
here is a quick recap of what we learned
in this lesson
the architecture of android operating
system is divided into the following
sections
linux kernel
libraries and android runtime and
application framework there are four
basic components of an android
application namely
activity
service broadcast receiver and content
provider adt bundle is a set of latest
android sdk
eclipse and sdk manager android virtual
device avd or emulator is a logical
device where you can install run and
test your application on your machine
ddms is the abbreviation for dalvik
debug monitor server
with this we come to the end of this
lesson